did anyone else do a double take at the
star studded cast of Netflix's latest
Mindbender The Talented cast wasn't the
only noteworthy thing about the recent
hit Leave the World Behind this one was
a real thinker with plenty of Easter
eggs and hidden elements added by the
director to make us think even deeper
about the movie's message here are some
things we couldn't help but notice about
the film it took a Keen Eye to notice
this seemingly minor detail from the
movie what seemed like some typical
Airbnb wallpaper in the bedroom Julia
Roberts and Ethan Hawk rent for their
family weekend away had a little more to
it as the film progresses and the
situation feels more and more dire the
water level on the wallpaper Rises too
by the end of the movie nearly the whole
bedroom is underwater the film's art
curator shared that the decision was
meant to evoke emotions while
disorienting viewers she said quote we
didn't want something that was going to
be obvious we needed something that
could evoke an emot tional response
without people really understanding why
the scene seems a little different the
other large artwork seen in the film was
a mural by artist Glenn Ligon similar to
the ocean mural this black and white
abstract painting changes throughout the
film becoming more and more chaotic the
increasingly glitchy appearance
mirroring the horrors occurring due to
what the characters believe to be a
Cyber attack on the country the artwork
was replicated by the movie's props
department at the permission of the
artist
and it sure added a cool layer to the
visuals of the film a running theme of
the movie is how the youngest Sanford
child Rose played by phah McKenzie is
binging reruns of friends it's a little
hard to get past the question of why she
didn't ask her mom why she was in an
episode of the show Julia Roberts guest
starred in season 2 of friends playing
Matthew Perry's character Chandler's
love interest but hey that might just be
some movie Magic we'll have to deal with
viewers had to have a serious eagle ey
to pick up on this one but some Savvy
fans found this hidden QR code which
appears when the TV shows a map of the
United States and where the Cyber attack
had hit it only shows for a few seconds
but the code when scanned links to an
abandoned amusement park in West
Virginia where it's rumored that
unnatural and traumatic events have
occurred I sure wouldn't get on that
Ferris wheel coming back to the artwork
in the house there's one more thing that
viewers might have noticed the
incredible home I mean seriously can
imagine living here is littered with
amazing art and all of that art was
created by black artists sourced by the
film's art curator the curator Raquel
chevremont shared that though Julia
Roberts's character is suspicious of the
home's owners the artwork could have
been a clue she added quote we also
wanted the artwork to signify gh's
stature and the family's wealth so the
pieces were by very well-known artists
and were not inexpensive did that scene
involving a dental emergency leave
anyone else feeling queasy Well turns
out that was the intention the director
shared that they purposefully used
prosthetic teeth to film the scene
rather than adding the effects in Via
CGI later in order to get a real
visceral and shocked reaction from the
actors and let's just say it worked on
the viewers too talk about new
nightmares unlocked whether you found
the deer to be cute or disturbing the
film put a lot of effort into getting
these CGI creatures just right according
to the director special attention was
paid to the way the light hit the
animal's fur he wanted to make sure it
looked accurate since bad CGI can
seriously detract from the flow of a
movie just add this to the list of
creepy scenes but when red Flyers rain
down on Ethan Hawk's character as he
speeds to safety who wasn't holding
their breath but what about the text on
the flyer while the characters took
shots at deciphering the foreign letters
it's actually a message from the
attackers warning against an imp pending
attack that will cause even more damage
than the loss of telecommunications
though whether this was a red herring
for the characters is still unclear the
Sanford's Family Clothing choices
weren't an accident father clay wears a
bikini Riot t-shirt hinting at his
forward-thinking Progressive nature son
Archie is seen in an obey shirt
referencing the 1988 film they live
which deals with society's obsession
with mass media and finally Rose's NASA
t-shirt h at her character's metaphor
for youth relying on escapism President
Obama um he's actually a huge movie
lover no the former president of the
United States didn't have a cameo in
this film unfortunately but you may have
noticed his name pop up during the film
credits that's because Barack and
Michelle Obama who were fans of the book
were involved in the production
including by adding notes on the
characters and theme of the movie did
you notice these hidden elements and
secret messages within the film are
there any missed be sure to tell us what
you thought of this mind-bending Netflix
flick in the comments
below